that's how you run videos builds machine
learning
it puts my mino that's now wheelworks
we tap deep learning
hare called jones formulas bossche bol and
meditations also thinking possible
using machine learning
what is the spot patch to the state already
service it nothing not theta  and every
runtime and did there comes a two parts
the features the mirror ruben she is the
roe input the the images the audio signals
recently they bite and then those labels
labels you gerard myth of a few
guys so is your vol xahmol trying to
find
education  in image and soul the needs to
go look at the image and door members
unfolding boxers and Woonerven face
zo in al-medinah la this time consuming
en our reborn so
people do like i have it is there is a
challenge die dan mee st lee
there  hsp is in progress in a couple or
technique is making a lot in
sweet and there cool active learning
and buyer to reward you have to shape them or
active learning
so the the trick is quite simple ex i  s
working how is that you maybe
you have little bit or did something to
your collection and
heart or deed that is m person or german
your hatred and envy it
painstakingly parents well she hears that
liefco terpstra vd to update
well you can train machine  lie 100m
percent of did one when you can make
dixons om the london eye realize eat
well not a machine that pillow conf
100x kind is a chest said how this
fiber s the she
on for the shore hear these parties
social media facebook in too  temples and
churros and what you can do in active
learning is
you je as continue me toe and the hot
date that is not sure about and their way
your uncle who
did city rotating and more i need to know
about
so on this de you have your  database that
she steps you the pace sent you go to 2
the machine owner
because that give you a hypothesis
and that her forces will take the other
nike percent of dating
this is one thing 2006 nothing
tricks a soldier without a box production
and sultry hai hai c  on flash
and boxes for less 13 16-en
they morris and van also conf and they might
be useful to have under a lookout
as new as your conflent machine even it
knows when you go to input of
en person who is i have a tone  that
not pike eat a dick so that
person will
label to detail and that costs back into
your machine learning two
each witham discreet and new up or
sister whoever starts with age0
if the training could for this look
band manual at age man  edsel we turn off
in you to apply that to the date that
you had a label like you the
labeling risks
when the database and the databases the
fishing team is labeled ever
had a spoon had a tissue for
training
so less active learning that works
came so enjoy the site and practical i
don't just uekerpolis conference can
our influence tricks like
what did and looks fair tip point of
dating to foil label he was sometimes of
similarity measure special features
week and  with showing you could not to
images in a video
so setup frame show look very simple
and expo dino very valuable to en op
time de expert den an etf en I speak
stuff that is more valuable to en always
frames the running gear you can
influence this  there is in that in the
selection process of fashion label who on
her disco points pay and weigh
that's where your office oc l rather can
auction good machine
and to convention that i got good
convention levels and ver you can c ok
so did for merge  with at nias
billion consumers construction dating oui
monsieur hill dat ruben ruben ruben
habit eksept
the machine label that news that has
this is well labels was on previously
labels so so the test dating of the
dating set was a privicy label graph
search from confessiones
de  african elephant accept it and
therefore you go back into
the database is yes and is correct in the
next training italian yes this way
vf corporation in the labeling between
the machine leu  nen en de you me how pissed
to gather
helps then label she did she and die club
dan stories on this
hello networks and the busy in whose dat
you can spent in its 20 cents or
rates knol i spent en of dating
databases and then silent  to be
performance something like e-people believe of
time and lasting this rise of
new area's information learning you
will see
popping is full high toilet roll is capture
and the sea badass crossing in
association with is there is subtle sleep
collecting data from people
yes  absolute rate may just stream it
your wedding change network shadow full
zip hoody so for you ds 2
white in the furry simbula and ds3 price
a bit so positive and
well if your mobile seriously tag
piston and enka price of a product
shampoo and me  live in nine tips to be
zoë too bridges between ech is the b